so yes Donald Trump is exiting the Iran
deal it's a geopolitical disaster but
our allies in the UK and the European
Union aren't just going to sit around
doing nothing it's actually quite the
opposite that UK and EU have agreed to
work to block the impact of the Trump
sanctions on Iran as far as European and
British businesses are concerned there's
a number of foreign secretaries and
foreign ministers from the UK and other
European countries who have signed a
joint statement committing to protect
European companies that do business with
Iran currently they're against Trump
pulling out of the Iran deal they're
against Donald Trump putting the
sanctions back in place it's really
important to understand that this is not
about defending the extremist theocracy
that is Iran I know I've said that
probably three or four times already
today but it's important to repeat we
have to understand basic geopolitics if
we make a deal and the other side
doesn't violate it we hurt ourselves
when we bail the EU and the UK seem to
understand that and I want to take it a
step further if you want the Iranian
regime overthrown but aren't into just
starting wars willy-nilly why would you
take action to make the people of Iran
suffer the same people of Iran that are
increasingly young and moderate and less
religious and more progressive are going
to be catalyzed into supporting
belligerent action by the regime if you
push them by increasing sanctions and
worsening their conditions if you are at
rumpus and some of them watch the show
and you think that by leaving the Iran
deal and making life worse for Iranians
you're gonna overthrow a regime you
don't like you're very very wrong and in
fact if anything you help the regime to
catalyze control and become more popular
because you are creating something to
fight against and in the 12 or so hours
since news of this EU and UK blocking of
the sanctions broke the internet has
just become overrun with comments saying
that Europe is choosing Iran over the
United States
this is stunningly dumb and
misunderstands the entire situation the
EU and the UK realized that the world is
worse off when you sanction Iran when
you eliminate an incentive for them not
to develop nukes the world is worse off
giving Iran the political capital to
behave poorly plus the economic
incentive to be more destructive makes
the world lose Iran can't be trusted I
agree they fund Hezbollah they fund
Hamas they make threats their actions
aren't good for other countries in the
region including Lebanon and Jordan and
many others so don't let them out of a
deal that at least has a framework to
hold them accountable and the EU and UK
are looking to protect their businesses
so that they can continue working with
Iran as if these sanctions had not been
put back in place but the problem is and
it was predictable immediately when news
broke that the UK and the EU were doing
this Donald Trump started threatening
European businesses saying if you do
this if you continue working with Iran
you are not going to be allowed to do
business with the United States either
and yet another instance where Donald
Trump is putting the United States at
direct odds with longtime allies trust
worthy allies allies that are not
belligerent that are not extremists
theocracies once again putting us at
odds with them and it's gonna get very
bumpy this is not going to end well yeah
it's totally predictable too because the
European Union the UK there were also a
part of this deal it's not as if it was
just between Iran in the United States
that's correct where are several other
countries involved so what are they
gonna do when they're backed into a
corner they have to choose one option
right Iran is not a country whose
politics I agree with and when backed
into a corner it's unlikely that they're
going to take actions that I agree with
or that any progressive should support
or like to see but they were following
the agreement and now the reality of
blocking the sanctions or of protecting
European companies becomes an issue it's
more complex than just signing a joint
statement particularly because of the
threats issued by Trump so the details
will have to be figured out it's not the
EU choosing Iran over the
yes it's the EU and the UK recognizing
that if you make a deal at this level of
geopolitical importance and the other
party doesn't violate it you can't just
pull out and punish them it's bad for
everybody
Trump doesn't seem to realize it or he's
willingly blind or ignorant but our
European and British allies seem to I
just don't know that they're gonna be
able to actually work it out now that
Trump is saying if you keep doing
business with Iran the u.s. is going to
punish you as well send me your thoughts
where is all this going what's the
endgame here is it war with Iran or is
it something else I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show today's program is
made possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman this is something I really
believe in better help gives you access
to fully licensed and experienced
psychologists and therapists through
your phone or computer I have been
talking for years about the problem
around people not seeking help because
of the stigma around mental health
services because of the cost of mental
health services and all you have to do
with better help is go to better help
calm slash Pakman answer some basic
questions you'll be matched with a
therapist that will be right for you you
can change therapists if you don't think
that it's a good fit it's less expensive
than seeing someone in person you will
still get the professional help and it
is unlimited you can talk to a therapist
every day from home or wherever you are
go to better help calm slash Pakman it
is so easy to sign up and get started
we've put a link in the description if
you're watching on YouTube better help
calm slash PA que ma n if you've been
wanting to talk to somebody but for
whatever reason haven't please go to
better help calm slash PA que ma N